today on the mat well show the same
people who fearmonger de bout the
coronavirus for months and months and
months on end are now applauding and
celebrating mass protests of people who
are not socially distancing and are
getting together in large groups so were
they lying about the virus or are they
okay with protesters infecting
themselves and each other and dying from
the virus those are really the only two
options and we'll talk about that today
also five headlines including drew Brees
quarterback of the New Orleans Saints of
course apologizing for saying that we
should respect the flag you said we
should respect the flag people are upset
and he apologized for saying it and in
our daily cancellation I will address
yet another false narrative that has
been spread widely online there's been a
lot of them recently especially this is
one that I think I want to address and
we'll get into that today let's begin
here setting the stage okay with this
report in The Daily wire this is from
Emily zanotti
it says Joe Biden the presumptive 2020
Democratic nominee is expected to attend
the funeral of George Floyd the
Minneapolis man whose death at the hands
of Minneapolis police officer sparked a
week of anti-police brutality
demonstrations across the country
according to a report from CNN plans are
being discussed but arrangements have
not been finalized the outlets said
Wednesday noting that while a spokesman
for Biden's campaign refused to comment
on the matter a attorney attorney for
George Floyd's family Ben Crump told the
network that Biden is expected to be in
attendance
Floyd's funeral will be held in Houston
Texas next week and it is expected to
draw hundreds if not thousands of
attendees there will also be a public
memorial service on Thursday in
Minneapolis okay now the first thing
that jumps out at you about this of
course is just the naked cynicism and
opportunism of demo' Biden and the
Democrats going to his funeral Biden did
not did not know George Floyd as far as
I'm aware has no connection to the
family why does he need to be there you
could say because George Floyd died
unjustly
all right well many people died unjustly
in the country every year unfortunately
in fact anyone who is murdered dies
unjustly all of the hundreds of black
men who died at the hands of other black
men every year in this country
they died unjustly Joe Biden's not going
to any of their funerals is he the black
people who have been killed by rioters
and looters over the last week died
unjustly David Dorn we talked about him
yesterday 77 year old retired police
captain st. Louis went out to stop
looters from ransacking a pawn shop and
was shot in the stomach and bleed to
death on the pavement is Joe Biden gonna
go to his funeral no of course not just
this one why well because it's a
political opportunity and everybody
knows that's the reason of course we all
know that everyone knows that Joe Biden
will be there for political optics to
imagine what a horrible human being you
have to be to do that to show up at a
funeral where there are truly grieving
people family members friends who knew
and loved him there that they are there
because for the same reason anybody
would go to the funeral of a family
member and you're just there for the
photo-op you are taking advantage
explicitly taking advantage of their
grief and pain for your own reasons I
mean it's it's no better than running up
to the casket during the wake during the
viewing and and taking a selfie with the
corpse it's exactly the same kind of
thing it's no less tacky and
inappropriate and offensive but that's
not the point that I want to focus on
this afternoon the fact that a Democrat
politician is a shameless opportunist
exploiting grief at racial tension for
his own gain that is hardly news we're
used to it it hardly even needs to be
pointed out I think there's something
else though that does need to be pointed
out about this and I will point that out
in just one second but before I do what
I tell you about red power bikes as I
began of course by thanking rad power
bikes and all of our great sponsors who
have stuck with us over the last few
months and ask you to you know always
just listen to us when we're talking
about these sponsors and if you hear
something that you like and you think
you need then consider supporting these
sponsors here's something that I really
think you need because we've been
for a long time and now it's it's time
to get back outdoors well that's where
rad power bikes comes in it's a cross
between a traditional bike and a moped
but it doesn't require a special
driver's license like a moped would so
that's you know there's there's not a
lot of red tape you have to go through
you just hop on the thing and have a
great time you go up to 20 miles per
hour without pedaling so you can get out
and about without getting all sweaty
especially in the summer months they're
great for commuting they're great for
going out on the trail they're great for
hauling groceries they're great for
hauling kids around and they're great
for going on a joyride just having a lot
of fun
unlike other ebikes they're actually
affordable plus to show appreciation for
those that serve us rad power bikes is
offering $100 off all ebike purchases
for active-duty military first
responders teachers and students you
know I I'm personally a big fan of
products that have practicality to them
but that are also a lot of fun
I need the fun element practical is not
enough you also need the fun rad power
bikes offers flexible financing for as
low as 0% APR and right now is a limited
time offer get a free accessory with the
purchase of a bike that's where I get a
free gift of up to a hundred dollars in
value and free shipping to the lower 48
states to get this special offer text
the word bike to 64,000 that's a bike to
64,000 text bike to 64,000 alright so we
have the opportunism and everything of
Joe Biden we know about that the thing
that I'm really zero inning zeroing in
on is the part where it says Floyds
funerals expected to draw hundreds if
not thousands of attendees and not just
thousands of attendees but attendees
from apparently other parts of the
country who will be flying in to attend
it what's interesting about that is that
for the past three months in places all
across the country and even across the
world funeral services have been
postponed canceled attendance has been
capped in many places graveside only
services were held with limited
attendance this in fact is what the CDC
recommended still recommends you can go
to the CDC website right now and read
their guidelines for funerals
and in fact let me read them to you it
says consider options for modified or
new practices that would be acceptable
to you and your family and family and
friends such as holding a graveside only
service consider whether it would be
acceptable to hold modified funeral
arrangements by limiting attendance to a
small number of immediate family members
and friends shortly after the time of
death now in many states this has been
not just a guideline but a requirement
and that's why in many cases people have
not been able to attend their own family
members funerals because of these
coronavirus restrictions now you can go
back in Google and look at some of this
stuff box has an article published in
April titled how coronavirus is changing
the ways we grieve and mourn the dead
and there are many examples of this kind
of thing people not allowed to bury
their own family members not allowed to
be there when their family members are
buried let me read just one example from
this article says Reverend Bill Parnell
a leader in the Episcopal Diocese of
Massachusetts told me that many people
in the 175 worshiping communities he
helps oversee our struggling with the
restrictions social distancing has put
on their grieving process for instance a
retired priest died from the carniverous
two weeks ago in Cape Cod leaving behind
his wife who was also infected the
priest family couldn't visit him while
he was sick nor can they attend his
funeral service because of travel and
space restrictions recall how large
funeral services were broken up by law
enforcement in some cases and especially
places like New York where de Blasio
threatened anyone who holds a large
funeral for a deceased family member he
threatened them remember this team
coverage for you this afternoon across
the tri-state we'll start with news
four's miles millar live in Williamsburg
where police miles are still upset about
last night's huge gathering there
well Stefan the mayor called that
gathering unacceptable and he said it
was the largest such gathering of any
type since social distancing rules took
effect few regrets today for Mayor Bill
DeBlasio after this controversial tweet
singling out quote the Jewish community
end quote
for a funeral in Williamsburg for a
prominent rabbi that drew thousands of
Satmar Jews I spoke last night out of
passion I could not believe my eyes
Marcia it was deeply deeply distressing
the mayor's choice of words drew
criticism with his former spokesperson
saying his tweet singled out the Jewish
community for persecution and the head
of the anti-defamation league saying
generalizing against Jews enlarge is
outrageous the mayor says he got word of
the funeral for rabbi hai Mertz and had
a security detail drive him to
Williamsburg to witness it himself
members of Jewish community we're
putting each other in danger they were
putting our police officers in danger
putting each other in danger putting
police in danger that's kind of weird
because now the mayor is suddenly
encouraging and celebrating large
gatherings you know even ones that
include actual assaults on police
officers forget about the chance of the
the cop can cops contracting koban 19
which is what the Blasio and many others
said would happen so this thing with the
funeral is just one example of the
incredible hypocrisy and double standard
that we're witnessing right now
thousands of Americans for months were
prevented from holding full funeral
services for family members and now
we're tossing that to the side so that
George Floyd can have thousands of
people at his funeral and this is
totally in keeping of course with what
we've seen the double standard that
we've seen across the board where again
for months people were arrested for
going to the beach going to church
gathering for parties even gathering for
family events and say in
Michigan you weren't allowed as a family
member to visit your family if they
lived in a different house people were
shouted at and shamed for protesting or
for going to the park for doing anything
in any group of any size and now this
same exact people who did the shaming
the same exact politicians who sent out
cops to arrest these people are
celebrating cheering applauding
encouraging mass gatherings of thousands
of people to protest ostensibly the
death of George Floyd but of course we
know these protests really have nothing
to do with George Floyd and aren't
actually protest at all but that that
that aside the change of tune the sudden
dropping of all that fear-mongering that
brought our nation to a standstill for
months and put 40 million people out of
work is just staggering
now some people some of the shameless
hypocrites who shut down gatherings for
months and are now applauding gatherings
have tried to justify the contrast de
Blasio is one of them Blasio was asked
about this at a press conference
yesterday and this is the the reasoning
that he gave this is the other piece of
the equation when you see a nation
entire nation simultaneously grappling
with an extraordinary crisis seated in
400 years of American racism I'm sorry
that is not the same question as the
understandably aggrieved store owner or
the devout religious person who wants to
go back to services so his answer is
that he ruthlessly shut down church
services and other kinds of protests and
other kinds of gatherings
not to mention shutting down hundreds of
businesses and leaving business owners
destitute but he's not shutting this
down because he personally feels that
this gathering is important while the
others were not he personally is moved
by their cause he wasn't moved by the
cause of the people who wanted to go to
church or wanted to run their business
or wanted to end the lockdowns over
protests he wasn't he wasn't moved by
that he's moved by this he agrees with
this and so that's why this is allowed
that's his answer
and that's how elected leaders mayor's
governor's across the country are
operating this is tyranny this is
flat-out tyranny and I'll tell you this
the next time they try to do one of
these shutdowns
because it will happen again we all
better just completely ignore them
completely you know continue on with our
lives as before ignore everything they
say we cannot forget this and I know
this is the kind of thing I'm talking
about it today it's a topic for the
podcast we'll talk about something else
tomorrow but it's not just a topic it's
not just some annoying thing that we
talked about today for a topic and we
move on this is I mean this really is
tyranny this is politicians who shut
down the entire country put peep for T
million people out of work and are now
basically admitting that it was all a
sham that it was all a sham and it's not
just politicians I read yesterday a
statement from public health experts
quote-unquote who were supporting the
protest the same public health experts
who shut down our society to save lives
supposedly are now supporting mass
gatherings of thousands of people and
then you remember this look let's recall
the way that health care workers
responded to protests and mass
gatherings recall this health care
workers who bravely came out to
interfere with and demonstrate against
protests because they and there you see
a guy you know standing in for the zoo
there's someone in a protest someone who
wanted to is in a car attending a
protest and you've got a nurse standing
there saying know it we're not gonna
allow that because they said it wasn't
safe to protest during a pandemic but
now here's what health care workers are
doing
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
standing off to the side during a mass
gathering of non socially distance
people applauding these are the heroic
nurses the ones who are recording tic
toc videos and now they're applauding as
thousands of people violate social
distancing just an absolute joke and
sham and and here's the thing let's say
that I agree for a moment because the
this is the justification right that we
keep hearing for this for this double
standard it's that well this is such an
important it's such an important protest
so it's so important let's say I agree
for a moment that these protests are
super important and way more important
than the lockdown protest way more
important than every small business that
was decimated and those small business
owners who wanted to go back to her way
more important than that let's say I
agree with that and let's say I agree
that George Floyd's funeral is somehow
for some reason more important than
anyone else's funeral if your grandma
died in the last three months and you
couldn't go to the funeral let's say I
agree that George Floyd's funeral is
more important than your grandmother's
funeral now I don't agree with any of
that of course at all but let's say for
argument's sake I do how does that
change anything we were told that the
corona virus is a lethal virus that
spreads easily in large gatherings and
if you get together like this many
people will die many of you will die
plus many others will get infected and
first responders will be put in harm's
way that's important part of this
because they they said another another
argument I'm hearing is that these
protesters have just decided that this
is worth the risk
because it's so important to them okay
that's all fine and good except that you
said it's not just about their own risk
they put other people at risk that's the
same exact argument that many of us have
been making saying that
if somebody wants to go out and they
want to go to a concert or they want to
go to the store or they want to go to
church wherever they want to go if they
want to take that risk on themselves
they should be allowed to do it but the
response from the people who are now
supporting the protests is that that's
not good enough because it's not just
about you you're putting other people at
risk
you're gonna kill my grandma by doing
this that's what they said so you can't
say now oh it's worth the risk for them
okay it's worth the risk for them but
what about my grandma they're allowed to
kill my grandma because this protest is
important to them so all that stuff that
you said it's either true or it isn't if
it's true then these protests are
killing thousands of people thousands
are going to die because of if
everything we were taught about the
corner virus is true
remember the corner virus still exists
there's no vaccine okay still out there
in fact it's wider spread now than it
was three months ago when all the
lockdown started so everything you said
about the carnival either it's true or
it isn't if it's true then these
protests are going to kill thousands of
people and not just the people who are
there thousands of innocent people who
did not make the decision to take the
risk
are gonna die my grandma might die your
grandma might die and our hospitals are
going to be overwhelmed again and many
doctors and nurses are going to be
exposed and many of them will die no
matter how important the protest is how
could that possibly be justified and if
you believe that black lives matter
wouldn't that be all the more reason to
oppose the protest considering that the
virus is now going to kill thousands of
black people because of the protest
these protests are happening many black
Americans are at the protest these are
happening many of them in black
neighborhoods in the city this is going
to decimate the black population if you
believe black lives matter and you also
believe all that crap that was said
about the corona virus then you should
be standing up and saying no no go home
you're gonna die if this is going to
kill you how can you say say I believe
that
I lives matter therefore I'm in favor of
thousands of black people infecting
themselves and others with a deadly
virus how does that make any sense now
on the other hand the other option is
it's that everything that we were told
about the corner virus was a lie and it
was never as deadly as they said or as
contagious and actually you can have
large gathering safely and it's not
gonna be a huge problem and you could
basically you know for the most part go
about your life that's the other option
that's what you would have to believe if
you support these protests unless you're
a psycho it doesn't care about the lives
of thousands of black people so those
are the only two options for everybody
who screamed about the virus for three
months and had advocated for shutting
down society because of it but are now
supporting the protests if you're in
that camp there are only two options to
explain your position only to either
you're a sociopath psychotically
applauding while protesters infect
themselves kill themselves and kill many
others or second option you were full of
crap in your fear-mongering about the
virus and you never really believed it
and it was all a lie so you're a psycho
or you're full of crap
there is no third option there really
isn't it is this is this is really as a
or B okay this is an A or B binary type
of situation here either what you said
isn't true and you're full of crap or
you're a psycho and you're applauding
while these people kill themselves now I
will allow by the way I guess for an
option C where you're both a psycho and
full of crap so there might there might
be an element of that too but I am
thinking that for most people it's
actually option B that you're just full
of crap and that what we were taught
about the corner virus was a flat-out
lie and though it is a virus that is
that is dangerous and that is killing a
lot of people it's not nearly as bad as
what they said
and many of the things we were told we
can't do we actually could have been
doing all along and 40 million people
were put out of work for no reason and
we decimated that our society we shut
down society we tore up the bill of
rights for no reason I think that's
actually what's going on here all right
let's move on to emails or no not email
sorry actually headlines is what I'm
searching for that's the word I'm
searching for number one drew brees NFL
star quarterback for the Saints was
interviewed by Yahoo yesterday and he
made comments that provoked a huge
backlash many people were very upset
reduced to tears over what this NFL
player said now I'm gonna play the
comments for you
I want you to prepare yourself they are
highly offensive very upsetting
in fact if you have any kids in the room
and you're listening to this I want you
to have them leave the room I don't want
them to be exposed to this at all it
could traumatize them like it
traumatized me
this I warned you what he has to say is
very very offensive and I think it would
you're not gonna be the same after you
hear it but anyway here it is everyone
is looking back now at Kaepernick's
protests from a few years ago and
obviously they were always about police
brutality and now it's coming back to
the four and a lot of people expect that
we will see players kneeling again
usually when the NFL season starts that
I'm curious how you think the NFL will
and should respond to that and of course
you're such a leader in the league what
is your responsibility as a leader in
climbs like this for the rest of your
teammates and players in lis well I will
I will never agree with anybody
disrespecting the flag of the United
States of America or our country let me
let me just tell you what I see or what
I feel when the national anthem is
played and when I look at the flag of
the United States I envision my two
grandfathers who fought for this country
during World War two one in the Army and
one the Marine Corps both risking their
lives to protect our country and to try
to make our country in this world about
place so every time I stand with my hand
over my heart looking at that flag and
singing the national anthem that's what
I think about and in many cases it
brings me to tears thinking about all
that has been sacrificed not just those
in the military but for that matter
those throughout the civil rights
movements of the 60s and everyone and
all that has been endured by so many
people up until this point Wow Wow
I am appalled I am frightened
I may have wet my pants frankly I may
have if you want to know the truth
listening to that I cannot believe or
maybe on second thought actually what
drew brees said there is totally normal
and fine and uncontroversial and just
like a completely standard and by the
way correct point of view that most
Americans agree with you know that maybe
that's it and yet because we live in an
enormous Lee stupid time and our country
is filled with idiots and whiners and
pathetic crybabies who should all be
deported to Jupiter those comments
provoked lots of anger and now get ready
for this part so that's what he said
almost every normal person in the
country agrees and says yeah I mean we
should respect the flag fantastic but
now here's the part that you definitely
saw coming drew brees has apologized and
in comments posted to Instagram he says
this is after about a day less than a
day of a backlash he says quote I would
like to apologize to my friends
teammates the city of New Orleans the
black community NFL community and
anybody I hurt with my comments
yesterday and speaking with some of you
it breaks my heart to know the pain I
have caused in an attempt to talk about
respect unity and solidarity centered
around the American flag in the national
anthem I made comments that were
insensitive and completely missed the
mark on the issues we are facing right
now as a country they lacked awareness
and any type of compassion or empathy
instead those words have become divisive
and hurtful and it misled people into
believing that somehow I am an enemy
this could not be further from the truth
and it is not an accurate flexion of my
heart or my character this is where I
stand I stand with the black community
in the fight against systemic racial and
and police brutality and support the
creation of real policy change that will
make a difference bla bla bla bla bla
bla bla goes on and on or not I mean
just just groveling groveling before the
outraged masses actually actually lying
about what he himself said he is
dishonestly assigning himself
nefarious motives saying that it lacked
empathy and sympathy are you talking
about you he was taught you we're
talking about empathy you were saying
you know empathy for our soldiers people
have that have died and that's what you
were talking about is a very empathetic
perspective that you had and now you're
lying claiming that you lacked empathy
when you actually didn't but I'm sorry
for the pain I caused I caused so much
yeah I'm sure you really caused a lot of
very sincere and genuine pain because
you said you said we shouldn't
disrespect the flesh I'm sure a lot of
people were very much in real pain over
that I'm sure it wasn't just a bunch of
performative outrage but he caved to it
and here's the thing that really
frustrates me you know when I see an
average person who attracts the ire of
the mob and because because they said
something normal and sane and rational
and these days that's how you're going
to attract the ire of the mob is by
saying normal rational sane things if
you go out and say things that are truly
insane and irrational you'll be fine but
the moment that you make the mistake of
revealing yourself to be someone who has
common sense that's when they come after
you now when you've got just an average
person not in the public light not rich
or anything not if not a famous
celebrity you know makes the mistake of
having common sense publicly and then
people come after that person and they
apologize now I don't like it I'd much
prefer that they stuck by their guns but
I get it I understand because they want
to have a job right and they don't want
people come into their home and throwing
bricks in the window and so they're
worried about their safety and the film
there's their family safety they're
worried about their financial secure
especially it's very sad that we live in
a country where you have to make those
kinds of calculations but so I get that
I'm really I just I'm not gonna hold it
against somebody when they make that
decision because I understand but
somebody like Drew Brees he's a
multi-millionaire famous celebrity he's
got the money to tell these whiners to
kiss his ass I don't know what drew
brees his net worth is but I guarantee
you it's it's over a hundred million
dollars so he could look at them he's
got all the money in the world you know
he if they if they run him out of town
so what I mean he's he's not gonna be
destitute he's not gonna be homeless on
the street he could look at them and say
and I mean worse even if he got kicked
off the team for saying this he's Drew
Brees somebody will hire him to play to
play football again I can guarantee you
that so he's in a position where he
could look at these people and say oh
you're offended by by the totally normal
common-sense thing that I said you're
offended that I said we should respect
the flag you're offended by that I guess
what I don't care I don't care oh you're
crying
so what cry some more cry some more
you're crybabies makes no difference to
me
it's your problem
go tell to your therapist okay how about
that that's what he could say but he
doesn't these people have nothing on him
they've got nothing to hold out what are
they gonna take from Drew Brees that's
what makes it to me that's what makes it
so just pathetic and and I always think
you know you consider what a stubborn
jerk I am already and I'm not rich and
famous if I was rich and famous can you
imagine what a stubborn jerk I would be
I mean most people dream of having that
kind of money where they can where
they're in a position where they don't
need to worry at all about what people
think of them Drew Brees has it and
doesn't use it just a shame okay number
two chick-fil-a home to the overrated
chicken and third best french fry put
out a statement yesterday and
here's what the statement says words are
not enough and they sometimes aren't the
right words but we want to say something
racism should have no place in society
not now not ever it cannot be tolerated
our hearts are breaking for our black
team members operators and staff and all
those in the black community who are
suffering and have suffered for too long
because of racism at chick-fil-a we know
we have a role in moving us all forward
we will listen we will be intentional
we will share I just wanted to play that
I just want to share that with you
because it's it's so inspirational and
courageous right to be a brand to be a
major brand coming out against racism
think about the courage that takes it's
not like everybody agrees with them and
and and feels the same way and so it
doesn't need to be said no it's not like
that at all of course we need people I
just I enjoy when you've got someone a
brand or anybody saying something that
requires no courage whatsoever something
that everybody agrees with and is it is
guaranteed to provoke zero backlash and
they say something like that but they
set it up as if it's going to be some
really bold statement and so the
beginning of this statement is we got
something we need to say sit down for
this all right sit down for this because
you're not gonna like it okay I'm ready
for the backlash but I gotta say this
I'm not gonna be scared to say this here
it is racism is bad all right and here's
a thing chick-fil-a I know why they put
the statement out because they're you
know they're hoping is chick-fil-a has
gotten a lot of bad press among liberals
and in the last very many years and
they're hoping that something like this
will change it's not going to change
anything they still hate you doesn't
matter what you do doesn't matter any
any of the groveling that you do any of
the dumb platitudinous platitudinous
platitudinous that's the word statements
that you put out makes no difference
number three and looting and rioting is
not over by the way it's still happening
here are the sights and sounds at a CVS
in Santa Monica
[Music]
everything in this store is completely
destroyed
[Music]
[Music]
platitudinous platitudinous that's a
word right I think that was a word that
I used anyway you saw all those grieving
people you know perusing a pharmacy for
stuff to steal
I like how casual the the looters are at
this point you see that most those
people aren't running because they know
that the police aren't going to show up
they've been doing this for a week now
it's like a full-time job of looting I
wonder if they set their alarm in the
morning and they do they say he's I have
what say 8 a.m. got to get out there hit
the pavement do some looting pack a
lunch and everything well I guess you're
gonna pack a lunch you can steal it but
you see them there now they're selective
about it as they're walking through
because there are entire aisles that
no-one's looted I guess because they
think like they walk through and they
say HUD do I do I need a whole case of
car chargers oh no actually I looted
that I stole that from a Rite Aid back
pasture the last Thursday so I guess I
probably don't either that's how that's
that's where we've gotten now where the
local government has so abandoned its
duty that looters are almost getting
bored with it that's the plan we're not
going to arrest them we're not gonna
stop them we're gonna wait until they
get bored and they've stolen everything
they could possibly need and can fit in
their homes and then they'll stop number
four this is interesting
Caryn's are now patrolling the streets
to yell at you for not doing graffiti
this is a plot twist nobody saw coming
watch this why are you guys removing
black life matters graffiti
well why do you want that to come off
[Music]
but so you don't care about black lives
that that's what this not enough to
leave up a message
right not not a great way to use your
white privilege ladies not a great thing
disgusting it's disgusting to clean up
graffiti on a government building
Karen's point here is that if you if you
clean graffiti off of something then you
must automatically be disagreeing with
whatever message that graffiti is
ostensibly supposed to be spreading so
then if that's the case I guess you know
somebody should go and paint spray paint
equality for all on the side of Karen's
house or in fact maybe right across our
forehead yeah you can't clean it off
Karen if you clay if you go home and
take a shower and clean it off what are
you saying you don't believe in equality
I mean that could that's the only
conceivable reason why you wouldn't want
it spray-painted across your forehead
five finally how about a legitimately
inspiring video okay this one is
actually inspiring actually courageous
no sarcasm just watch this it's pretty
great black kids is Chicago get killed
every single day where is the black eyed
man in Chicago where a day when black
people keep black people they don't come
out and do this crap the only $10
discharge is when a white person Toshi's
get the racist yeah the rest is because
we're pissed white cops is wrong to wake
up the king of request and that's for
sure but if in modesty should matter at
all times so what are you fighting for
what are you fighting for you're not
here to fight injustice your mom will be
stuck violence
it's not about blacks okay press I am
black I'm not oppressed I am very visual
person what about systemic issues where
I am black of what we wanted to be
another graph like I do whatever you
have this fuse this is the culture we
have this case you want to do what you
want you do it stop the first thing on
people to accept that your Prezi and now
I am not oppressed I am black
they oppress your fasting and rendering
into your minds which is not true that's
my point
violence is wrong period it's not about
blacks you agree that whites cubelet
whites - right have you seen any white
person coming out and saying white life
matter or white no problem is a balance
problem the black steel bluffs in black
neighborhoods every single day I've
never seen a black mother in those
neighborhoods never when the black
person kill a bloody LeBlanc
neighborhood their commanders there when
the police pounds you know what other
police pursuit black light murder
stop the hypocrisy nobody gives me
seriously nobody you hear that message I
am black I am not oppressed I am free
that is the definition of a of a of an
inspiring empowering message that that
is empowering the word powers are
empowering something that expresses that
gives power autonomy to a person well
the message of I am free I am not
oppressed that is a saying I'm oppressed
I'm a victim that's the opposite of
empowering that is rejecting your power
and your freedom that what you just
heard there is an empowering message but
then you see you could kind of laugh
about it because of how how ridiculous
this scene is where you've got a black
woman obviously an immigrant talking
about the fact that she's free and then
you've got a white woman trying to
convince the black immigrant that she's
oppressed and could could there be a
better illustration of the way that the
Democrat Party works the white woman in
that discussion she is a representative
of the Democrat Party a bunch of white
people trying to convince black people
and minorities that they're oppressed
and getting upset
offended if they won't agree that
they're oppressed but great stuff great
stuff from that from that woman
alright we're gonna move on to our daily
cancelation before we do you know these
leftist tears tumblers are something
that especially in these trying times I
think we can all turn to for hope and
kindness I don't know how you get
kindness from a tumblr but yet but you
can okay and here's the great thing
though our double tumblr deal is back
but it's only available to our exclusive
membership to your all access the all
access membership tier is our premier
level of membership all access members
get to participate in all access live
which is our brand-new interactive
programming feature where we you know
one of the daily wire host sit down
every night we have a conversation very
relaxed casual a lot of fun I think all
access membership now includes two of
the irreplaceable leftist tears tumblers
the tumblers are overflowing with tears
at the thought of this deal
finally all access members also get the
benefits of our other membership tiers
including an and free website experience
access to our live broadcasts and show
library access to the shows mail bags
all of that stuff you get three hours of
Ben Shapiro show dedicated editorials
from yours truly that would be me
okay you get that from I don't know why
I'm wielding this tumbler around while
I'm talking and so you got to go to
Daley wire comm right now / subscribe
daily wired.com slash subscribe to join
all access get 15% off with coupon code
Walsh
that's daily wired.com slash subscribe
see you see you there I'll get that
later okay let's go to our daily let's
go to our deal good thing there was
nothing in that I was lying about having
something in it as you can clearly see
for our daily cancellation we're going
to be canceling the promoters and
propagators of false narratives
obviously there are a lot of false
narratives out there like the false
narrative that about racist police
hunting and killing black people you
know that's the narrative that's fueling
the destruction of our cities right now
I've already dealt with that this week
want to take a smaller more specific
example so we can kind of look at the
anatomy of a false narrative how it
works how it spreads how its concocted
so here's a tweet from some random
person I don't think this person is
someone in the media or anything like
that but I'm pointing to it because last
I checked this morning anyway that tweet
was pushing seventy thousand retweets
seventy thousand which is a lot and here
it is it says they were all charged for
the exact same crime the exact same day
and in the exact same city but y'all
don't see the problem and then it shows
screenshots it doesn't give us a link to
the does not give us a link to where the
screenshots are from which is red flag
number one and it shows how three people
were arrested for violating curfew in
Greensboro North Carolina but they were
all given different bond amounts with
the black guy given the highest bond
amount at five hundred bucks and the
obvious insinuation here is that it's
racism I mean they did the exact same
thing right how could the black guy get
the highest bond doesn't make any sense
the exact same thing no difference is in
the situation well already we've got um
one red flag there's no link another red
flag is just the very idea that they
would blatantly set bond based on race a
policy like that would be shot down by
the Supreme Court in 60 seconds flat
okay so what's really going on here I
think we should we should take a look
and see I mean maybe it's true maybe in
Greensboro North Carolina they've got a
policy where if you're black you get a
higher bond amount as I said I would be
shocked that that policy has not been
challenged yet by the supreme court but
it's a it simple it is possible so I
went and I took a look at the story and
I found it wasn't hard WUF my news
to.com and this is where this person got
the information for this massively viral
tweet going all over social media people
are buying it CA goes oh well look at
that isn't it racism and everything
let's read the entire context okay now
the first two guys
for the first two guys the information
is exact exactly what the tweet says
Troy herring 21 of Greensboro was
charged with violating curfew his $100
bond was posted in his next court date
will be September 15 jeff chuan su 21 of
Stokes tail was charged with violation
of curfew his bond was set at 300
dollars and his next court date is
September 15th but then we get to the
black man and there's actually a little
bit more information
it says Malik Perry Davis was arrested
after he climbed a statue in downtown
Greensboro following the protest that
was dispersed Greensboro fire crews used
the ladder truck to remove Davis from
the statue before he was arrested his
address is listed in Jacksonville in
Onslow County but he said he was from a
mix of Greensboro Jacksonville and
Greenville and Hawaii according to
social media he lives in Greensboro he
was charged with curfew violation and
his bond was set at five hundred dollars
his court date is September 15 hmm okay
now it's all coming together because
this this viral tweet the person put the
tweet together they coincidentally
forgot to include all of that additional
information Malik was arrested not just
for violating curfew but because he had
climbed to statue and they had to bring
in a fire truck to get him down okay
and apparently he has no fixed address
he's from a mix of several different
places including a place 5,000 miles
away and he and he says he's what from
one place but social media says he's
from another place and then he also says
yeah by the way I'm also sort of from
Hawaii and all these other places all
right
well that's why bond was hired right
they're gonna raise bond if you're a
flight risk if they can't tell exactly
where you're from and one of the places
is 5,000 miles away that that's gonna
raise your bond and also they're gonna
raise bond if while violating curfew you
pulled a stunt that required them to use
the fire department to come get you and
they're using the fire department while
there are riots you know across the
country and things are being set on fire
so you know they
might really be thinking we need this
firetruck potentially for something more
important like a burning building now we
have to use these fire department
resources to get you down from a statute
because you refused to come down you do
something like that yeah your bonds
gonna be higher and there you go
now so it's very obvious and there's
there's nothing racial about this no
racism in fact this guy's lucky for only
a thousand dollar bond given that he was
violated curfew and they had to take him
down from the statue with a fire truck
they only charged him with violating
curfew flight risk
only $1,000 bond he did pretty damn well
but we're of course we're not told that
and what we know is that with false
narratives you know for one thing it's
oftentimes it's not that things are
being just totally made up out of whole
cloth now there is that sometimes you
have things totally made about hope with
Michael Brown hands up don't shoot that
was whole cloth fabrication but
oftentimes it's based on a morsel of
truth it's just that it's the the false
part of the narrative comes not from the
part they tell you but from the part
they don't tell you and the reason it
spreads is because most people are
concerned with stuff that confirms their
priors that's all they care about they
have prior held beliefs they have they
have their own biases and their own
prejudices in their own perspectives
that they're bringing to it and all
they're looking for is confirmation of
what they already believed so a whole
bunch of people said oh yeah well I
already believe that racism you know
that there's a pervasive systemic racism
especially in the south this fits in
nicely with that and so I'm just gonna
spread it and assume it's true why would
I do the work to see if it actually is
true all that really matters is you know
the ideology and everything else so that
person has cancelled all of the
propagators of false narratives are
canceled and I trust that now that I've
done this there will be no
false narratives and I have just solved
the problem you're welcome and we'll
leave it there thanks everybody for
watching thanks for listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
our supervising producers are Mathis
Glover and Robert Sterling our technical
producer is Austin Stevens edited by
Dani D'Amico and our audio is mixed by
Robyn Fenderson the Matt Walsh show is a
daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 20 from CNN to the minnesota
government prominent leftists defend
political violence
public health officials change their
story on coronavirus and the rioters
kill robert e lee again plus the mailbag
check it out on the Michael Noel's show
[Music]